ذكريات طفوله لو وفتها عدسات كاميرات
تسللت لمراهقه صاخبه بعدها هي قضيه العصر
قعد فيها الامير هاري فتحه كتابي مذكراته
33 قصه خبريه من اصل 147
ستبحثها المحكمه في قضيه انتهاك الصحافه
لخصوصيه الامير الشاب فذوق قدم دعائات عده
ضد صحف ديلي ميرور
لجمعهم اخبار بطرق غير قانونيه بين
1996 و 2010 اولها يعود الى احتفاله بعيد
ميلاده الثاني عشر حين تحدثت جيل مرر عن
حزن والدته لعدم تمضيه الوقت الكافي معه
وعدم تقبله لتلاقي والدين المدرسه ملاعبها
المراهقه الحفلات علاقات الامير الشاب
وشؤون داخليه اخرى كخلافاته مع شقيقه ضمن
القصص التي سيقدمها نجم ملك بريطانيا قصص
تجادل صحب بريطانيه بانها كانت مطروحه
للعامه وليست خاصه او سريه مقدمه سردا
بديلا عن كيفيه نشرها فيما يؤكد الامير
هاري ان مثل هذه القصص يمكن ربطها بسجلات
المدفوعين لمحققين خاصين وادله ظرفيه تثبت
استهداف هاتفه واختراق رسائله الصوتيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات